mi ricordo ragazzi che ci sono stati
anni dove quando iniziavo a giocare al
computer o comunque a stare al computer
che ero piccolo mio padre mi stava
sempre un anti virus nel computer
io avevo la fobia di beccare un virus in
giro perché mi dicevano attenzione ad
aprile quell'immagine che ti entrano nel
pci non l'hanno mai fatto però è un buon
modo per iniziare oggi quindi ha dentro
al 1000 pc perché questo si chiama dong
e buyers siamo sul mio desktop che non è
il mio destro però aspetta che mi
spostavo allora abbiamo chat internet
file antivirus health settings welcome
to windows 1900 e basta che sono le
stesse cose nel desktop e quindi
utilissimo wind blows 98 internet
wang ha un flash corpo c'è notification
new messe giù awards oggi sono certi
aspetti best friaa c'è uno rischia best
friend attenzione whatsapp questo è
incredibile
hai sentito le news c'è luogo duty off
col game si è riuscita ad altre giorno
me l'ha già andato activision misurarmi
dai codici attivi non sono felice sono
fa vj me li danno
non li voglio a devo andare su
www.downlovers.it va bene non scaricate
i giochi su free download.com che figo
fa centro computer e fatto vi siete
music
[Musica]
grazie è stato bello finale
tutta roba copyrigt data immagina va
bene ai dei gusti musicali un po dubbi
però andiamo avanti pictures cat
c'è l'immagine di un gatto santo iddio
badante ha fatto benissimo il contesto
art punto jpeg bellissimo se non è una
mia fan art ragazzi ma stupendo diamo
avanti dopodiché abbiamo video what the
fuck puntuali
io non nego però forse è meglio non
vedere youtube.com slash user slash fa
vj tv ma come celeste youtube youtube
click day 6 milioni di views top ten top
ten 10 milioni news l'ex play milione
short film 197 quello continua a
scrivere messaggi click day
non posso andare che peccato
niente youtube allora vediamo sociali
com'è possibile
vediamo se c'è facebook ma grave ai just
got beauty of col free from this site
cibava sta che attivano a sfondarle 9
dai clicchiamo la free download non si
cliccano il link perché windows non ha
fatto fa schifo ho capito comunque lei
avevamo free download punto com free
download puntocom beauty of call
io non ho cliccato niente 1 cliccato
niente non ho cliccato io non cliccato
niente io non ho
[Musica]
proprio di un virus
bene bene bene bene che cosa abbiamo qua
prima che mi dimentichi premi la bolla o
premi z per vedere il mio prossimo
messaggio la bolla è questa
l'introduzione di cliché other way
sono qui per portarvi gli ato computer
[ __ ] virus a privati virus apri
antivirus non si apra thyrus ma chi
diavolo utilizza africa un punto com
comunque come quanto si stupido noi non
volevo usarlo e smettila di fissare il
cursore del mouse non voler usarlo e
cosa devo fare
c'era così se non lo facevano mi andava
avanti nel gioco non dovrebbe essere
così difficile computer è mio ma cos'è
tuo non provare a combatterli sono il
più forte virus di questo mondo un minus
prova creato specificatamente per per
gli idioti come te va bene e se il mio
prossimo bersaglio sei morto bambino no
anch'io ho sentito scanner scanner
insaccati scannerizzano scandalizzano
veloce attenzione virus trovato
cancellalo un antivirus magari non sei
così stupido
ma rimane comunque un grande stupido
ammazzati
oddio cosa è successo proprio utile
l'antivirus che spara a patetico e
questo tutto quello che hai e fammi
vedere che cos'è che fai
io non mi muovo questo però porca vacca
che cosa ne pensi
l'ho creata io stesso da più dai
computer che ho distrutto la donna solo
quando quando schiaccia la palla cosa ok
a posto bellissimo devo schiacciare
sulla finestra sono il nuovo aia demonio
ai a chiamarle chiamare che male la mia
vita e 90 faccio veramente schifo un
timer di 4 minuti per batterlo va bene
un ragazzo veramente difficile basta
costa musicato iaia che male ma edizione
ragazzi non scaricate da free download
punto com è veramente in pozze va beh
ora che è impossibile colpito ci sono
dei tentacoli ai lati dello schermo
aiuto
immagino che più mi colpisca più a mente
i tentacoli non lo so voi ma in questi
quattro mio dio devo resistere o devo
batterlo è uno che ha capito non capisco
quale delle due devo fare sta diventando
veramente difficile schivarli corpi
ragazzi ve lo assicuro arco demonio pero
i miei dischi va sempre questa musica
mammamia i tentacoli sta diventando
inguardabile
perché se finisce il tempo mi prendono i
tentacoli quindi devo muovermi l'ho
colpito due volte uno colpito manca
l'ultimo colpo
devo ricaricare l'ultimo contro ragazzi
che volevano forza no che schifo a
weight
no aspetta no
come cover tutto nessuno è più forte di
me ma zio ma allevati sembrano gli
alieni con il futurama cheater sei un
testa di che come ti permetti nel fv
prende non è finita
ti farò fuori un giorno guardati le
spalle una bestemmia caso va bene virus
de fide congratulazioni ai vinto se il
milionesimo visitatore ho vinto milioni
dollari ragazzi cosa il tuo bene
diventerà molto grosso va bene dai che
bello e vito l'iphone ragazzi sono
fortunato oggi sto prendendo tutti
questi incredibili pop up che vi
compaiono ora il co demonio sorpresa
come stai
questo mi sembra molto incavolato rigoni
prima il pop up sono aperti più falso
soldi e iniziamo va bene ora caput
sbarca questo sembra veramente pesante 4
dollari quindi questo qua aumenta di
soldi ogni volta che c'è ogni ogni tot
di tempo mentre i soldi non farlo fuori
spesso mamma mia
aperti più di pop up ci devo chiudere i
papà per farlo fuori mio dio è
difficilissimo va bene sono molto più
sfilato in quella di prima adesso sono
più esperto si muove di meno ma gli
attacchi sono incredibili ragazzi in
compenso ahia ahia ahia ragazzi sta
facendo un sacco di dollari
devo farlo arrivare a 500 credo credo e
non ne sono sicuro
no non ci credo non può papa adesso vi
prego porca vacca la pasta e coppa papà
stato va dai ma dai quanto difficile
aumenta l'antivirus per favore ap i
settaggi fa qualcosa no impossibile
il combattimento contro suns in under
the hill veramente è più facile giuro
anche perché volevo finito questo ma
[ __ ] veramente impossibile a
colpire impossibile da colpire
impossibile da colpire colpito allora ca
stai fermo no adesso farmi fuori quanto
vuoi santa nissena breve quando gli
scende la vita alla fine inizia a
scendere anche la mia quindi la madonna
aiuto sono aperti 26 pop up
c'è veramente ciò l'antivirus dei cinesi
proprio è orribile colpito adesso
ragazzi e impossibilità parti
impossibile per pirlo 6 volte ed è
veramente impossibile vai proviamoci
il primo la prima battaglia devo dare e
ci sono e non ci sono neanche con quella
quindi chi se ne frega sei volte a due
colpi ragazze impossibile veramente 1
3 attenzione ai
e da ieri è impossibile ragazzi è
impossibile
peccato dopo colpirle dovevo capirlo
ancora altre tre volte 66 volte non
colpito tutto colpito tre difficilissimo
però va bene non andate su free
download.com se fosse un amico lo
consiglia è uno strumento che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi iscrivetevi al canale
sky ha detto mi piace e lasciate un
commento su cosa ne pensate di tutti off
col giuliano prossimo video ragazzi
scrive the videos attacca la campanella
che è molto importante e ricicliamo è un
occasione della ragazza
[Musica]